Hi I'm Buck Schwartzmore!
come on down to Crazy
Buck's Democratic National Committee
where we are massively overstocked on presidential
candidates
and we have got deals that you can't afford
to pass up!
Like a nationwide 15$ minimum wage,
free college tuition,
Medicare for all!
or a thousand dollars cash to every American
every month of the year!
We've got so many giveaways we're practically
giving them away!
Howdy folks, Steve Hightower here at Big Steve's
Republican National Committee.
And we've basically have two options for you
so,
if you like old white guys,
jackpot!
Tougher immigration restrictions?
We'll get em for you!
Crippling trade war?
We'll do that too!
Big bailout, to cover all the losses from
the crippling trade war?
You can have that,
or... or you can have the complete opposite
of all of those things
it basically, it could go either way.
No credit?
Bad credit?
Recent violent felony conviction?
You can still have it all!
Subsidies for green energy!
Free universal pre-K!
Paid parental leave!
What about 12 new Supreme Court Justices?!
Taxes, we'll cut them.
Regulations, we'll slash em.
National debt?
[impotent noises]
But if somebody kneels at a football game,
we're totally gonna stick it to that guy on twitter.
So if you value freedom and equality under
the law for all Americans
regardless of race, religion, gender or sexual
orientation,
I promise you, it po- uh we, it,
we might
bomb Mexico, boom!
Or not, it could go the other way too so-
Free US Treasury bonds to every newborn child
in America!
Something about banking at a post office?!
We're even going to break up Facebook and
cap credit card interest rates!
See one of them used to be Libertarian but
he was a Republican before that.
And the other actually started as a Democrat
and then became a Republican
and then joined the Reform Party and-
and then back to a Democrat and then Republican
again
and then independent, uhm,
uh but now I guess he's a Republican?!
So-
you can trust us!
Ten billion dollars in slavery reparations!
Nine trillion dollars for climate change stuff!
It's all real!
and we're gonna overturn Citizens United!
Because we have to get money out of politics.
So go down to route 51 just past the Starbucks,
don't even look at the Starbucks, just pass
the Starbucks and take a hard left!
Just off highway 88 between the Chick-fil-A
and the Exxon.
Big Steve's Republican National Committee,
our inventory may be low,
but our convictions are even lower!
Crazy Buck's Democratic National Committee,
we've got the greatest deals in history,
which we are doomed to repeat!